aren't you excited to play with Dirk he
is the greatest the great test you're
going to love it here
greatest city in the world
we're definitely going to the tournament
this year
[Music]
[Music]
I can't wait to share the court with you
and a legendary sir Dirk
would you like to see him you see like
he says spirit is strong but I am afraid
there is not much time left
okay he's down to ten minutes a battle
my but come you will make him very happy
sir Dirk
remember you can fight for this house
for as long as you like
don't go but I don't have much time left
maybe only six seasons of pigs that's
fine that's totally fine is now a good
time
sir Chris tops is here too oh yes yes
Dirk someone special wants to see you
hello my euro father you shaved your
beard
Tyson oh that's a kristaps Chris law
stops you're on Elsa Mavericks I am yeah
Lord mark this is truly a wonderful gift
almost makes up for the time I took a
giant pay cut okay to stay with house
Mouse you use a cold on charmer
Paulson's all right okay not good okay
well I will let you boys load to talk
about whatever European things you guys
want to talk about like wine and bread
cheese I get it alright later dudes mark
is actually it's very cool guy your
grace I want to learn everything off to
teach me let me bask in the light of
your wisdom I will tell you what is the
most important yes please loyalty for 56
years I have formed only House Mavericks
colors even as those colors went through
a questionable rebrand and though I
showed my opponents no mercy I made no
enemies
because I betrayed no house
me why did you abandon your house your
families well I was on house NICs say no
more okay yikes yikes never mind
Chris tops Jews and swear your loyalty
to house more Forex yes I do
Rosa in the name of Dirk Nowitzki of
house mavericks
i hereby declare you sir next Dirk I
can't wait hold on with all due respect
he said I was the next Dirk like like
I'm gonna go oh that's right okay Chris
stops you will be as an ex Turk until
Luka comes of age right but I'm already
there's the go through night right I'm
scoring roughly 20 points a battle what
if maybe both of you are the next duck
we do a double Dirk's yeah it could be
double ducks
it'll be triple Dirk screw the truth of
those people Turks who is the audience I
think I also told Maxie cleavers at ease
the next meal sir our next battle starts
in 8 hours we need to start your
stretches oh don't thank you JJ I'll be
right there
all right boys time to play some
basketball
[Music]
what the hell coos oh come on probably
would have been more off-target if I let
you alone well the arrow costs 200 gold
face 200 gold foot right hey weren't you
cutting ties with them yeah but I go get
that arrow back it's gonna be a
collector's item
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alonzo we're not sure it's safe to climb
in co2 boots it's not one disease you
will give Rondo all your minutes think
of the fast bricks
I yearn to toss your lobs Oh think of
the spacing would you let me play power
forward yes anything even though I'm
clearly a center so whatever you want
because together we will bring back show
time too bad Lord gems would never trade
me here he just hates house Lakers he's
always been jealous of big mark it's
never rich handles Dell but you'd have
to give up your entire young core for my
rights I would trade every single one of
them for just a chance to play with you
between you and me they're a bunch of
fools and overhyped Squires even the
ball boy for long though
good riddance dear Manda's Oh from a
father and once he's gone we'll bring in
a real Lord Commander like Jason wait
stock just us son of us are you
completely mad he saw us don't train me
I'm really good except for shooting free
throws in three-pointers layups but
uh-oh is the number two pick he was the
number two pick the things I do for
rings oh come on guys
shake it off you're fine just a little
lay off push from the greatest day in
the realm someone going to help us up
well I suppose there's always next year
oh yeah
[Music]
you
sometimes I like to pretend that I'm
subscribed to bleacher report on YouTube
I get all the notifications and I can
show my support for game of zones but
alas I'm back in China's now don't get
YouTube here but I do wonder will they
ever do an episode about the Guangdong
southern Tigers I certainly hope so